on this episode of Mookie threesome
we've got Deadpool tubes of toothpaste
and interpretive dancing and actor
dancer choreographer and prankster
Robert Hoffman is here and this is movie
Robert thanks for joining us in
completing the movie threesome yeah so I
feel like a lot of people watching this
probably know you from step up to the
streets there's dancing there's acting
which passion kind of came first for you
dancing was the initiator for sure
dancing was something that since I was a
toddler was just like what else would be
more cool to do doesn't everyone know
dancing is the coolest thing you can do
period see that's the things that you
say everyone knows him from like from
step up from me it's his youtube channel
normally thinking if they have a YouTube
channel it's just dancing
it's just comedy you do a mix of all
three of these the comedy the director
pranks what works totally me to my
disadvantage because YouTube's gonna
work a lot better if you have a
consistent thing but I just can't if I
have it's always best idea next like oh
I have this great idea to do a wind-up
guy that pumps the air maniacally but
you're not helping you're not humping
air in the direction of people who well
yeah yes what have you found out about
people in general what are you doing so
much so much really good semi deep for a
second here like pranking brings you to
presence in the coolest what it's
talking about that vis means that my
deep deep yeah I like you do like one
two three four pranks and you're so
scared and you're so like invading the
world I'm showing up really any a crack
than the drawer yes or arrested or
shamed it and then all of a sudden like
you realize what society has taught you
is not true everyone isn't an affliction
shirt wearing jerk that just wants to
knock out anyone they're having
something wrong but rather the world is
playful in their game and if your
reality is the most dominant reality and
it's one of fun then you just feel like
so clear and you're so present and the
world is your playground and shame on
anyone who's not in it with you you know
I mean really interesting experience to
prank are you a big fan of comedy movies
was one that Deadpool immediately to my
top 5 yeah every line is like that's a
great joke that's never been said before
it was different type of are rated
comic-book movie studios are gonna
wanted a lot of those now but it also
brings us to last week's weekly wager
which I just want to put out from the
very beginning that we both made
not necessarily here were the numbers
that we bet last week I bet 61.5 million
you bet
I don't want to sail out it was a bad
bet 56 million the actual total was 135
million that's not including Presidents
Day my god Robert why did this movie
make so much money because it's good
because it's not hack it's not formula
and you won't make something good ideas
yeah
every line a great idea what in the ass
it's great that was ever said that
that's a great word play this week's
loser should comes from YouTube user a
high Mach who says hashtag loser should
eat a toothpaste sandwich for the record
if more than used for brushing is
accidentally swallowed get medical help
or call poison control center right away
okay here we go
say stop making stupid bets on that too
I feel like oh hi mark is trying to kill
me on set so he can steal my job I'm
almost certain this is relatively talk
this is really gross it looks wonderful
alright next week we're gonna bet on
race for me I am going to say nine point
five million Tiffany what do you got a
12 12 okay who's gonna win
you are we just have to McCall's make
sure you guys put your loser shows in
the comments below use the hashtag loser
should on Facebook and on Twitter
I can't wait to see if you go two months
without winning a bet this is awesome
but don't worry cuz it's gonna get a
little better for you because right now
it's time for today's topics
controversy out there right now it is
called freebooting Robert as a content
creator can you tell us a little bit
about exactly what freebooting is it's
when people rip stuff off of YouTube
where people can monetize and then put
it on Facebook which is a big sharing
machine giving no credit and essentially
taking away all of that person's
potential to monetize someone wanted to
take your ninja video off of YouTube put
it on Facebook you don't see a dime of
that nothing well and that's not saying
when somebody uses a youtube link and
post it to Facebook because then it
still drives people back to YouTube so
that's fine also on Facebook you can't
really search things so you don't know
until it shows up in your feed with 30
million views and you have 50,000 on
your YouTube okay I mean that's true you
tell a lot to be fair YouTube did it
took you to a little bit to be able to
monitor that stuff and they were smaller
when they started its biggest Facebook
do you see even from your YouTube
channel like a difference in numbers
where when they do take clips out and
put it on Facebook does the number on
YouTube is it less 500% you know I'm
kind of being debbie downer right here
but I have a passion for this because it
really does so for like small time
creators really stinks right now I I'm
looking forward to the next website
that's like hey we're never gonna flip
it on you don't worry about being heavy
because it's time to get fun game time
it's this game is can you do the what
what is that I'll tell you it is all
about dancing and the dancing right now
is gonna be between Robert and Tiffany
I'm going to say a dance move they're
gonna have to do set dance move and I'm
gonna see who did it best professional
dancer you do now but wait well what but
here's here's what I have to let you
know though I can see you do his move
you don't know what the hell it is and
then you do it you could win some points
here we go Robert the first one is
called the sprinkler sprinkler real
moves aren't even done
okay
I don't do sound effect though oh you
see you have for me you started then you
bailed Robert gets the point the Cabbage
Patch it's good it's good
he's getting into a nasty nagging
trouble first one first one you kind of
oh you really committed though Tiffany
gets the point uh now here's the last
one the Tiffany Smith it's a very white
girl name so I'm going to do the white
girl move what's the white girl Tiffany
when you go to a dance club what is the
Tiffany Smith I bet a lot of them know
no hands I'm like people don't get my
business I'm gonna have to give it to
I'm sorry Tiffany but you get the point
nothing and I like that you beat the
professional dancer but no no it's like
get out of my way yeah I like it I would
have to spend the winners we love
winning and forever cool so I got to you
did which means that I'm gonna make you
do a dance move that Rob's gonna teach
you see on my head staying in place when
my body's moving and you can do with
your head have you ever seen this done
head isolations like that I'm literally
turning my face I'm like here look at
this this is an assignment you'll get it
really good of insulation a head goes to
the right now your body goes to the
right your head goes to the left which
makes your head stay in place now
reverse the Christian get back in here
you totally chickened out not gonna end
the show today no just like I thank
Robert for showing me how to dance I can
now go to the club's Tiffany for being
Tiffany thank you guys for joining us
alright guys well if you want to check
out more of this guy it made me learn
some dance moves and make sure you
follow him on social media at Hoffmann
Robert and on YouTube at touch rocker
and make sure you check us out subscribe
right over there check out past episodes
right there and then download the
Fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone and then check us out next
week on